hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute nach langem warten
endlich das schwangerschafts update
machen kurz vorweg der moral ist heute
leider nicht mit dabei der muss arbeiten
dort heute spätschicht aber ich habe mir
gedacht ich mach das jetzt trotzdem kurz
ganz alleine damit ich eure fragen
beantworten kann
als aktuell bin ich jetzt in der 29
schwangerschaftswoche schon das heißt
ich hab nur noch knapp 11 uhr um bis zur
geburt also eigentlich nicht mehr so
lange ich finde die zeit vergeht auch
viel zu schnell und es geht alles
ruckzuck und ja noch elf wochen und habe
schon unser baby ihn daher in den armen
also heute erfahrt ihr übrigens auch was
es wird ein mädchen oder ein junge und
das verrate ich euch am ende aber am
anfang möchte ich noch so ein paar
fragen beantworten und zwar habe ich mir
so ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben
also zuerst mal aktuell wie gesagt 29
der woche mir geht es zur zeit ganz gut
mein bauch wird halt immer runder und
immer dicker und immer größer ist wird
immer schwerer
vor allem nacht ist als ziemlich
schwierig zu schlafen weil ich
eigentlich noch rechts oder links
schlafen kann manchmal erwische ich mich
dass ich dann aufwache und liegt auf dem
rücken und das total mega weh weil sich
der bauch im total rein drückt aber auf
jeden fall wird es immer anstrengender
aktuell geht es mir ganz gut dass mit
dem rücken wurde jetzt auch besser
ich weiß auch sechsmal bei der
krankengymnastik also bei der
physiotherapie und hab da am rücken
wieso akupunktur bekomme ich das war
kein akupunktur sondern es wurden immer
nur so wird der rücken so ein bisschen
angeregt und dann durfte ich auch schon
wieder gehen als es wird echt viel
besser und ich muss halt immer beim
sitzen darauf achten dass ich nach dem
hohlkreuz sitze weil das verursacht
anscheinend die schmerzen und ich stehe
auch nicht mehr so lange macht beim dreh
auch immer wieder pause und wenn man
schon beim dreh sind also aktuell geht
es ja immer noch von mir drei videos die
woche das möchte ich auch noch eine
gewisse zeit so beibehalten
es macht mir natürlich auch sehr viel
spaß es ist zwar anstrengend aber es ist
ja nicht so ich muss sowieso was kochen
oder was packen weil ich das gerne mache
und wir müssen auch aus essen und ob es
an die kamera mit läuft oder net ist er
dann für mich im prinzip egal von daher
kann ich ja weiterhin die videos für
euch drehen und der murat unterstützt
mich ja immer mit dabei der ganze
haushalt
er macht den boden und saugt immer und
wischt immer und nimmt mir da eben die
arbeit ab ich mache die küche und den
rest deswegen ist es ganz gut
ja später wieder wahrscheinlich wieder
schimpfte aber naja ich hab ich's halt
erzählt was sich bisher zu meiner ersten
schwangerschaft so ein bisschen
unterscheidet ist bei samira wasser
meine erste schwangerschaft und man hat
ja nur einmal die erste schwangerschaft
das heißt da ist die aufregung viel
größer und ich habe mir damals zu dieser
zeit also so ende 29 woche habe ich mir
dann schon ein paar sachen gekauft
natürlich ich habe mir überlegt was für
kinderwagen nehme ich was für ein auto
hole ich hatte schon ganz viele
klamotten ist sicher klar weil es halt
ziemlich aufregend war dieses mal ist es
so ich habe im moment eigentlich noch
gar nichts gekauft weil ich habe von
samira noch ganz viele sachen und ja
deswegen freue mich da erst mal alles
raus was ich habe und schaut doch
einfach was mir noch fehlt was mir
aktuell noch fehlt ist ein kinderwagen
und ein autositz
und zwar deswegen weil wir damals als
wir noch studentin war also ich habe
studiert als ich schwanger war
und da hatte ich einfach so eine
günstige variante gewählt so für den
übergang oder ich habe gedacht wenn eine
gute marke weil ich immer dachte das
wäre eine deutsche marke was aber dann
leider doch nicht und leider hat sich
herausgestellt dass der kinderwagen eben
doch nicht so gut war und ich hatte
ihnen damals im internet bestellt
konnten auch nicht mehr reklamieren
auf jeden fall war er nach drei monaten
ungefähr kaputt deswegen brauche ich auf
jeden fall einen neuen kinderwagen und
auch immer ein auto sitzt denn beim
autositz war das problem also es war
auch so ein kombi set das heißt ich
hatte den kinderwagen da waren buggy mit
runter und auch den autositz und da war
halt das problem der autositz hatte
keine isofix also falls ihr nicht wisst
was es ist das kann man mit isofix
befestigung praktisch den sitz direkt am
auto und dann wird's kind eben noch
angeschnallt und der sitz kann dann
immer im auto mit drin bleiben und ist
dann auch immer fest und das finde ich
immer ganz gut weil wenn ihr zum
beispiel mal fahrt ohne baby also wenns
baby zum beispiel zu hause bleibt und
ihr geht einkaufen und der sitz liegt
eben locker im auto dann ist es ziemlich
gefährlich falls ihr mal bremsen müsst
und das ding schießt euch dann eben
durchs auto aber auch wenn das kind
mitfährt
immer ganz praktisch mit isofix weil
daneben da einfach viel mehr stabilität
mitarbeit und das hatte ich damals eben
nicht und da war es auch wirklich mal so
da hab ich mal scharf bremsen müssen und
samira saß im sitz- und dann ist das
jetzt komplett irgendwie umgekippt also
das war ziemlich nah vor der
schockmoment aber ja deswegen brauche
ich da auf jeden fall neuen sitz
vielleicht kennt ihr da irgendwas und
kind mehr normal was empfehlen
ich schaue mich auf jeden fall selber
auch noch mal oben in verschiedenen baby
fachgeschäften denn dieses mal bestelle
ich nicht aus dem internet sondern lass
mich auch gut beraten
aber vielleicht habt ihr da irgendwelche
marken die ihr mir empfehlen könnt beim
kindersitz und bei also bei der auto
schale und beim kinderwagen da war ich
auf jeden fall sehr dankbar
also was sich auch unterscheidet mir
wird es ziemlich warm und ich komme
immer total schnell außer puste auch
schon beim reden ich schwitze grad schon
obwohl ich eigentlich nur hier sitzung
rede auf jeden fall was wollte ich noch
erzählen dann haben ganz viele eben noch
gefragt was unterscheidet sich so zur
ersten schwangerschaft also auf jeden
fall bin ich nicht mehr so fit wie
damals mit zweiundzwanzig muss ich halt
schon dazu sage aber ich glaube es hat
mich letztes mal schon gesagt und jetzt
haben halt auch gerade die warmen tage
wobei ist jetzt im moment gerade geht
aber auf jeden fall ist es ziemlich
anstrengend jetzt habe ich auch wieder
so eine phase in der ich total müde bin
liegt wohl daran dass ich nachts gut
schlafen kann aber ansonsten
unterscheidet nicht nicht so arg viel
weil auch bei samira war die
schwangerschaft ziemlich ruhig ich habe
zwar damals studiert und jetzt bin ich
eben aktiv war aber so unterscheidet
sich eigentlich nicht nur kann ich mich
eben nicht so oft ausruhen weil es habe
schon die samira und den morath und die
wolle arbeit aufmerksamkeit von daher ja
aber beide unterstützen mich von daher
steht ganz gut
viele hatten mich dann auch gefragt ob
ich wissen was zusammen miras geburt
erzählen kann das mache ich jetzt auch
ganz kurz und zwar hatte ich bei samira
den entbindungstermin arm
10.11.10 genau 11 2010
und als der termin da wasser mira noch
nicht da sie kam dann erst am 14
auf die welt und das ist auch so eine
ganz süße geschichte denn ab 14 nächster
sich gleich also es war dann war mir
also am 13 november kennen
wahrscheinlich viele die selber
schwanger sind oder schwanger war
und zwar habe ich dann meine mama zu mir
gerufen habe sagt mama komm mit mir
heute ein bisschen beim putzen und beim
aufräumen eigentlich total das bedürfnis
die wohnung sauber zu machen und alles
herzurichten und das ist ja so dieser
nestbau trieb den mann und er hat es
gemacht und ich hatte halt währenddessen
so den ganzen tag immer rückenschmerzen
und das gab's dann immer so im stich im
rücken und hut gezogen irgendwie aber
ich habe mir nichts dabei gedacht ja und
irgendwann habe ich dann gemerkt das
fruchtwasser ausgetreten war auch jetzt
nicht so wie man es aus dem fernsehen
kennt zur platschen alles ist raus
sondern einfach so ein war anscheinend
ist in der fruchtblase dann habe ich den
moment zwar so ich hab erstellen morath
angerufen und habe gesagt du ich habe
jetzt pizza gemacht und schiebt es jetzt
gleich in offen wann bist du da nach
exakt ja so in zehn minuten bin ich da
und ich hab da noch katja noch kein
stress um keine eile
wir hatten damals auch kein auto und
waren gerade auf autosuche sogar
parallel noch und er wird gerade von
seinem schwager zum zu uns nach hause
gefahren und dann habe ich eben gemerkt
ok fruchtwasser ich ausgetreten und es
geht los
wobei ich jetzt keine wehen gespürt habe
aber der schmerz im rücken war
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen die venen
und habe ihn dann noch mal angerufen hat
gesagt du ich schieb die pizza doch
nicht rein ich friere sie ein weil ich
glaube wir müssen so langsam ins
krankenhaus auch noch kein paar keine
panik und keinen stress ruf keinen an
wir gehen alleine und das einfach nicht
was die massenpanik auftritt vor allem
habe ich gesagt meine eltern ich zum 1
deinen eltern oder deiner mama nix das
eben später 100 leute im krankenhaus mit
stehen
im endeffekt war es dann leider doch so
also meine eltern waren da meine beste
freundin nada die hat übrigens gerade
kuchen gebacken weil sie am 14 november
nämlich geburtstag hat und das war auch
ganz witzig eigentlich ziels mit dabei
sein
naja ich hab sie nämlich angerufen habe
sagte nadja es geht los wir müssen ins
krankenhaus hall stunde ich gehe immer
mit
und sie sagt einfach am telefon du es
eilig backen kuchen ich kann nicht und
ich habe mir gedacht okay gut dann hat
net und 2 später hatte der angerufene
hotline konnte ich viel unterwegs ich
bin unterwegs also der das irgendwie
keine ahnung nicht irgendwie realisiert
dass es wirklich losgeht weil wir hatten
eigentlich ausgemacht ich rufe sie nicht
mehr an weil immer wenn ich sie die tage
vorher angerufen habe was ich schon
total in panik das eine mal saß dem zug
und hat sich schon 1000 szenario
überlegt wie sie aus dem zug aussteigen
kann und dann schnell zu mir kommen kann
damit sie die geburt verpasst auf jeden
fall stand der die naht ja noch da dann
war damals noch einen freund mit dabei
und waren glaube ich zu achten dass im
krankenhaus als es war wirklich krass
mache ich dieses mal auf keinen fall so
diesmal keine ahnung wieder murat steht
sein kann sage ich sie brauche und ja
dann aber im krankenhaus aber dann war
alles noch ganz ruhig und sie haben auch
gesagt heute kommt das baby nett weil
einfach keine wehen da waren und dann
habe ich damals auch mittel bekommen
dass ich noch schlafen kann also
praktisch sein schmerz hemmendes mittel
weil so leichte bauchschmerzen hatte ich
dann schon und ich hab da einfach
praktisch über nacht nummer kraft
gesammelt und am nächsten tag war dann
halt die geburt ja ich hab ja echte
überraschung schon verraten weil samira
kam ja am geburtstag von meiner besten
freundin nadja naja wie auch immer
damals wurde die geburt eingeleitet
also ich hab dann zur tabletten bekommen
zum schlucken damit ich eben wehen
bekommen und das war eigentlich das
schlimmste was ich bisher im ganzen
leben erlebt habt weil diese künstlichen
seen die kommen halt plötzlich und dann
immer direkt nacheinander durch
eigentlich kaum pause noch das zu
verarbeiten und zu verarbeiten und es
wird immer schlimmer und immer schlimmer
ich weiß aber während der geburt noch
ich mache nie wieder ein kind und ich
adoptiere am besten nur noch kinder aber
jetzt im endeffekt mal über steht ja
alles und die geburt verlief dann auch
super und war dann auch echt schön als
meine mama war mit dabei und demokrat
war mit dabei und dafür lief echt alles
super ich war dann drei tage im
krankenhaus und stammt nach hause und
jetzt wird's bald 5 ja aber es war halt
echt schön vor allem somit der nadja
dann weil er dann ja die von mir an
ihrem geburtstag kam als das war echt
total schöner moment und ja also richtig
toll
ja das war ein kurzer auszug zu samir us
geburt und da in dem zusammenhang wollte
eben gefragt hast du jetzt eigentlich
angst vor der geburt oder nicht weil ich
ja schon mal eine erlebt habe und vor
meiner ersten geburt war es so da hatte
ich gar keine angst weil ich mir gedacht
habe komme ich finde ich die erste frau
ich bin auch nicht die letzte die jetzt
ein kind auf die welt setzt und ich war
sogar als ich im siebten monat damals
schwanger war bei meiner schwägerin bei
der geburt mit dabei weil ihr mann
nämlich umgefallen war
und sie hat gefragt ob ich dann nicht
kommen könnte und ich war mit dabei und
hab gesehen wie meine nicht die
praktisch auf die welt kommt und es war
echt schön wobei es ein bisschen
problematische geburt war als kind war
steckengeblieben und kann 1000 ärzte und
war schon so ein bisschen schockmoment
aber es hat mich damals trotzdem nicht
veranlasst jetzt eben die angst zu
bekommen vor der geburt weil ich schon
so ein ziemlich optimistischer mensch
auch bin und weiß amiras geburt wie
gesagt was dann auch so ich hatte keine
angst davor und war sehr positiv
eingestellt und sehr optimistisch und
habe zwar dann danach bestimmt so zwei
drei vier wochen gebraucht bis ich
gesagt habe okay ich würde schon wieder
ein kind wollen aber nicht jetzt sofort
sondern erst in ein paar jahren und es
hat sich dann auch mit der zeit so
entwickelt am anfang habe ich echt
gedacht ich mache wahrscheinlich nie
wieder ein kind aber nicht wegen der
schmerzen sondern einfach weil die
samira so der mittelpunkt in unserem
leben war oder immer noch ist und ich
einfach so diese aufmerksamkeit gar
nicht mit einem anderen kind teilen
wollte als irgendwie war das damals für
mich unvorstellbar noch mal ein kind zu
bekommen bis genau so sehr zu
eben wie die samira damals und es ging
sogar über zwei drei jahre so
wobei ich mir immer sehr viel kinder
gewünscht habe und ja letztes jahr kam
dann wie gesagt die samira und hat sich
dann so sehr ein geschwisterchen
gewünscht vor allem der schwester am
anfang hat sie sich ein bruder gewünscht
haben was eine schwester
aber ich meine ich kann seine steuern
und dann hat sich eben auch bei uns so
eigentlich der wunsch entwickelt okay
wir wollen wieder nachwuchs und jetzt
bin ich auch ganz froh dass wieder
nachwuchs kommt und es ist wirklich so
als man liebt auch sein zweites kind
service erste und sind weiter dann
gleich auf jeden fall ist es jetzt so
ich bin so immer noch positiv
eingestellt also sehr optimistisch und
ich denke mir einfach ja gut die gebote
sicher was das dauert ja nicht mehr
lange und ich habe zum ersten mal
überstanden weil es auch jetzt
überstehen
natürlich habe ich schon wieder alles
was heißt angst angst ich so ein
bisschen übertrieben aber ich möchte
natürlich zum beispiel keine geburts
einleitung also wieder diese künstlichen
seen
mir wäre es am liebsten ich hier jetzt
natürlich erwähnen uns wird alles
natürlich wie möglich laufen
vor allem habe ich mir damals auch
gesagt ich wollte halt keine pda also
diese betäubung dass man praktisch diese
wenig spürt wollte ich nicht weil ich
einfach gesagt habe wenn ich das jetzt
legen lassen weiß ich ja nie wie sich
das anfühlt und deswegen wollte ich
damals natürlich wie möglich und habe
dann gesagt okay die schmerzen stehe ich
jetzt durch
und es ist ja nur für eine gewisse zeit
deswegen aber trotzdem also ja jeder der
sich eine pta legen lässt hat auch seine
gründe und es gibt ja es gibt positive
und negative rückmeldungen also jeder
wie er es möchte
aber ich wollte damals nicht und ich
hoffe auch diesmal dass die geburt so
natürlich wie möglich verläuft und wird
mir trotz der schmerzen die ich letztes
mal erlitten habe und trotz dieser
erfahrung mit den künstlichen wen würde
ich mir glaube ich diesmal auch keine
pda legen lassen weil es geht ja vorbei
und naja mal gucken wenn es soweit ist
auf jeden fall wie gesagt angst vor der
geburt habe ich nicht aber ich wünsche
mir eben das ist er natürlich verläuft
und natürlich dass wir dann beide auch
gesund sind
das ist für mich eigentlich so dass
wichtigste vor ein paar tagen weiß auch
meine hebamme bei mir zu hause also ich
mach das halt immer so ich hab jetzt
alle vier wochen immer ein arzttermin
und meine hebt aber kommt auch einmal im
monat vorbei
das letzte mal war es jetzt das erste
mal da dieses mal mache ich jetzt doch
keine geburtsvorbereitung wo ich mache
auch kein yoga ich kam einfach nicht mit
dazu und wird aber demnächst ein paar
schwangerschafts übungen anfangen also
ein bisschen beckenbodentraining und so
weiter und wird das sogar mit meiner
freundin anne von barrick ist so ein
paar übungen auch euch zeigen wenn euch
das interessiert also da können damit
gerne in die kommentare schreiben
auf jeden fall ist es aktuell so ich
habe im moment ich glaub etwa was ich
habe jetzt nicht mehr gewogen aber das
letzte mal was so hatte ich elf kilo
drauf also elf kilo seit
schwangerschafts beginn und mein bauch
umfang ist auch aktuell 1 meter also das
ist schon der hammer
also schon ziemlich groß geworden aber
mal gucken wie groß ist noch wer das
baby ist jetzt aktuell ungefähr 30 cm
groß und wiegt knapp über ein kilo
und ja ich frage mich wie groß der
brauch jetzt noch wird ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr wie groß ihr letztes
mal war aber mir kommt er jetzt schon
ziemlich größer vor als bei samira aber
ich glaube beim zweiten mal geht's
einfach viel schneller und einfach mal
schauen wie es wird bei mir eine
freundin körper die samurai setzen wir
dabei und sie darf jetzt beraten auf 7
bruder oder eine schwester bekommt was
bekommen isabella dumm ich nehme ich
schon einen namen raussuchen
aber wir sehen uns noch nicht ganz und
wir wollen ja auch wissen nein wir
wollen ja auch wissen vielleicht habt
ihr noch tolle vorschläge für ein
mädchen gehört
also wieder samira hatte scan wert weil
das die verrät die ganze den namen und
deswegen habe ich jetzt noch mal weg
geschickt
ich wollt ihr euch ja eigentlich den
namen das geschlecht über eine torte
verraten also die dann im innern
entweder rosa oder blau ist und dann
auch so ne schwangerschaftswoche machen
oder ein baby bauch torte aber im moment
kam ich einfach nicht dazu es kamen die
minions dazwischen die ich für euch
machen wollte dann habe ich noch zwei
andere motiv torten schon abgedreht die
ihr demnächst alles sehen und ich denke
ich mache auf jeden fall trotzdem noch
eine schwangerschaft orte ich hab auch
schwangerschafts capex schon gemacht als
baby cupcakes für ein baby shower party
zum beispiel aber ich habe mir gedacht
komm ich sparen euch jetzt nicht länger
auf die folter und verrats euch jetzt
einfach was es wird auf jeden fall wird
es mich sehr freuen wenn ihr mir zum
beispiel ein paar schilder
namensvorschläge macht ich finde es ist
amira ist ja auch ein arabischer name
gibt es zwar auch im türkischen wird
aber anders geschrieben und anders
ausgesprochen
samira ist arabisch und semra war die
türkische variante um ein echter name
also ich heiße eigentlich nicht sehr
lied ist es mein spitzname sondern mein
name ist sallah hat das ist auch ein
arabischer name deswegen finde ich
arabische namen ganz schön oder eben
türkische auf jeden fall finde ich es
immer ganz gut wenn nahmen auch eine
schöne bedeutung haben
also da lege ich eigentlich auch viel
wert drauf und ja vielleicht habt ihr ja
schöne vorschläge ich kenne ja auch
nicht alle namen und suche jetzt auch
schon die ganze zeit aber wie gesagt
darf die samira da bisschen mit
entscheiden
und sie hat sich eigentlich schon
festgelegt und jetzt gucken wir einfach
mal und es wird mich natürlich auch
freuen wenn ihr mir ein paar vorschläge
sendet wegen dem kinderwagen auf jeden
fall sollte es so ein kombi kinderwagen
seien also mit schale und mit buggy mit
drin und für eine auto schale also das
finde ich auch super
und ja zur schwangerschaft updates
fallen wir ehrlich sind immer so schwer
weil ich immer nur dasitzt und
eigentlich nur rede aber nichts mache
und ich hoffe ich konnte euch jetzt
viele fragen beantworten falls ihr auch
noch weitere fragen habt stellt sie
einfach unten in die kommentare
ich würde das nächste update dann wieder
so eben vier wochen machen dann habe ich
ja nur noch sechs sieben wochen bis zur
geburt ich denke da kann ich euch dann
wenn es euch in
hier zum beispiel auch mal so eine
ausstattung zeigen wie so eine
erstausstattung und wird da einfach
zeigen was habe ich noch von samira was
kann jetzt noch neues mit dazu und was
habe ich gebraucht was habe ich nie
gebraucht und kaufte mir auch jetzt
nicht oder ja einfach so vielleicht habt
ihr da fragen und ich beantworte sie
euch dann das nächste mal auf jeden fall
hoffe ich dass ihr viel spaß hattet mit
der familie hatte ich ganz schön viel
spaß da kommt jetzt auch schon wieder
übrigens hat sich grad bisserl in ihrem
zimmer ich habe den beiden nämlich obst
und gemüse klein geschnitten damit
bisschen was machen können und jetzt
sieht es ganz so aus dass klein
geschnitten und mit knete vermischt und
mit einem horn mit so einem löffel
verrührt na ja ich wollte halt bisserl
zeit ist hotmail spielen aber ja muss
man ihr noch bisschen erklären dass man
mit lebensmitteln es spielend na ja das
mache ich auf jeden fall jetzt gleich
nochmal und welt die zwei noch gleich
schminken den kombis in kinderschminke
und ja dann freue ich mich schon wieder
aufs nächste mal und gespannt
tschüss
ja opel geplant ist wollte er eigentlich
des geschlechts über eine torte verraten
also eine torte die dann innen rosa oder
blau ist wobei ich immer so ja dieses
geschlechterspezifische netz so gut
findet aber ich habe trotzdem noch in
rote dazu bereit gestellt naja was solls
aber ich komme im moment einfach nicht
dazu von torten zu machen
ich habe neulich schon die minions und
so weiter gemacht und hat wetter nicht
gestimmt und weise heißen wetter wollte
ich eigentlich noch in die küche stellen
und stundenlang etwas machen wobei es
trotzdem gemacht habt zwei torten für
euch gemacht aber